It would be difficult to check out everything
leaving Netflix in August, so we have a list
of the best of the best films you have to
watch before they disappear.
Between now and the end of August, sign into
your Netflix account and load up these movies
you won’t want to miss.
Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas, Terry Gilliam's
psychedelic satirical black comedy based on
Hunter S. Thompson's book of the same name,
is a flick you either love with every fiber
of your being, don't really understand, or
haven't seen at all.
Or maybe you just don't like it, because that's
fair too.
The film divided critics upon its release
in May 1998, largely for its pendulous nature
and bizarreness that can make your head spin.
But in the two decades since, Fear and Loathing
has picked up a swarm of fans who will go
to bat for it.
Set in 1971, Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas
centers on journalist Raoul Duke and his lawyer,
Dr. Gonzo, as they take a road trip from the
sunny skies of Los Angeles to the sin-filled
deserts of Las Vegas.
What begins as an effort to document a race
devolves into an exploration of an otherworldly
dystopia that gets more and more haunting
the further Duke and Gonzo venture in.
"There was evidence in this room of excessive
consumption of almost every type of drug known
to civilized man since 1544 AD."
Some think Fear and Loathing is Gilliam's
worst film by a mile, while others have called
it, quote, "a stylish and faithful adaptation
of a lasting classic of American literature."
Hurry and find out which side of the argument
you fall on, or revisit an old favorite, before
Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas departs from
Netflix on August 1st.
Want to indulge in some silly scares as summer
winds down?
Before August 1st, load up Netflix and watch
the first four installments in the over-the-top
horror franchise Final Destination.
Each entry in the saga centers on a group
of young adults who fight for their lives
after a friend of theirs is suddenly struck
with a vision and warns they will all die
in a freak accident.
All seems okay when the group isn't involved
in the accident their friend foretold, but
the hand of fate soon swoops down and plucks
them off one by one, killing them via elaborate
Rube Goldberg-style coincidences.
There's no avoiding Death or their final destination:
the grave.
Though none of the Final Destination movies
have been critical hits, they've performed
fairly well at the box office and have amassed
something of a cult following.
They're campy and inane, and the perfect movies
to mindlessly watch after a long summer day
spent lounging in the sun.
Writer-director Edgar Wright and writer-actor
Simon Pegg started the Three Flavours Cornetto
trilogy with 2004's zombie romp Shaun of the
Dead, then built it out with 2007's Hot Fuzz.
The comedy stars Pegg as London police constable
Nicholas Angel and his Shaun of the Dead co-star,
Nick Frost, as Angel's overeager partner,
Danny Butterman.
"There was a bit earlier on that you missed
when I distracted him in the Cuddly Monkey
and then I said 'Playtime's over' and I hit
him with the peace lily."
"You're off the f---ing chain!"
After Angel realizes that his flawless track
record of catching baddies has made his London
superiors angry, he's transferred to the quiet
town of Sandford and partnered up with the
action movie aficionado Butterman.
Angel reluctantly settles into the calmness
of the countryside town and gets used to having
the oafish Butterman at his side, but things
take a dark turn when a string of "accidents"
unleashes horror and chaos onto Sandford.
The two cops buddy up to discover the culprit
and true meaning behind the crimes.
Hot Fuzz, regarded as "everything an action-comedy
should be," leaves Netflix on August 1st,
in case you didn't already know.
"Nobody tells me nothin."
Directed and co-written by Luc Besson, The
Fifth Element takes place in the 23rd century,
when Earth is on the brink of collapse hundreds
of years after a race of aliens collected
four elemental stones from Egypt in 1914.
It's up to Korben Dallas, an ex-special forces
major and current flying taxicab driver, and
Leeloo, an orange-haired humanoid who crashes
into said taxicab, to combine the four elemental
stones with the fifth element to prevent a
massive ball of flaming death from hurtling
into the planet.
Dallas and Leeloo meet a host of colorful
characters along the way, which makes their
already unforgettable experience that much
more memorable.
Be sure to catch The Fifth Element before
it leaves Netflix on August 1st.
Got your Twinkies?
Got your shotgun?
Well, get ready to roll, 'cause the zombie
apocalypse is about to be over, and you don't
want to miss your shot at killing some undead
creatures.
Ruben Fleischer's runaway hit horror-comedy
Zombieland follows a group of four humans
roaming the zombie apocalypse.
Making his way from his dorm room in Texas
to Ohio to see if his parents are still alive,
geeky college kid Columbus meets three strangers
who become his makeshift family: sisters Wichita
and Little Rock, who have some unique ways
of dealing with chaos, and zombie-killing
expert Tallahassee.
There's humor and gore, violence and a kickin'
soundtrack, an appearance from Bill Murray
as a fictionalized version of himself, and
even some romance - you know, something for
everyone.
Zombieland is set to jump off Netflix on the
very first day of August, so hop to it.
Then, look forward to catching the sequel,
Zombieland: Double Tap, in theaters on October
18th.
Javier Bardem has taken his fair share of
turns as baddies in films like Skyfall and
Pirates of the Caribbean: Dead Men Tell No
Tales, but no villainous character Bardem
has embodied comes close to the psychopathic
assassin Anton Chigurh in No Country for Old
Men.
"What business is it of yours where I'm from,
friendo?"
Set up as a cat-and-mouse game, No Country
for Old Men begins with a discovery: Llewelyn
Moss steps into the aftermath of a drug deal
gone wrong, and finds $2 million in cash sitting
in the back of a truck.
It's an unexpected payday for Moss, but it
changes his life forever when Chigurh sets
out to recover the money.
An adaptation of Cormac McCarthy's novel of
the same name, No Country for Old Men is thrilling
and bleakly funny as it explores themes of
religion and fate against the arid backdrop
of the Lone Star State.
Your last chance to catch it on Netflix is
August 11th.
Directed by Garth Jennings in his feature
debut, The Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy
brings the weird and wonderful novels of the
late Douglas Adams to life in a way that no
previous adaptations could really manage.
"Excuse me"
The Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy centers
on Arthur Dent, an English everyman who's
having a particularly troubling day.
He learns that his house is scheduled for
a bulldozing, that his friend, Ford Prefect,
is actually an alien journalist, and that
Earth will be demolished to clear space in
the solar system for a hyperspace bypass.
Arthur's only shot at surviving is to hitch
a ride on a passing spacecraft, and thus he
embarks on a journey he never could've imagined.
Our unlikely hero discovers that everything
he thought he knew about life has been wrong,
and everything he needs to know rests in a
book called The Hitchhiker's Guide to the
Galaxy.
Also starring Zooey Deschanel as a humanoid
named Trillian, Hitchhiker's Guide has been
hailed as a delightful sci-fi treat, and it
leaves Netflix on August 20th.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.